Thanks means this is a joint walk with
no girl alone without felt manisha I'm
Ann Sue Ann machet Tanner halls and I
want to tell you about the today about
the dynamics of evolving social groups
let me start by telling you what i mean
by involving social groups so little
groups in which the court would members
are the ones who selecting which new
members will join the group so one
example which will be clear to anyone in
this room is academic departments so in
academic departments the quad faculty
members are the one for selecting which
candidates will join the department's
another example from the academic domain
is the national national academy of
sciences who appoint members suggest and
vote on which new members would be
admitted an example from a different
domain is from the Freemasons so if one
wants to join a freemason freemasons
lodge almost all of the current members
of this Lodge need to approve his
admission a different examples are
condos so if one born to become an
apartment owner in a condo he first need
to pass an admission committee which is
composed of corn the condo tenants now
the very high-level question that you
want to ask you is what are the effects
of different admission rules on the
group composition as the goofy evolves
and I'm going to be a bit more formal
about this question in the next slides
but I first just want to tell you that
this question can be asked in two
settings so first we have a setting in
which the group grows so it doesn't have
a constant stars like an academic
department or the National Academy of
Science and we can also consider the
same question in setting where the group
is of a fixed size like countenance so
renal apartments is fixed and we have
results for both settings but for most
of this talk I'm going to quantitate
understanding of wine groups and I'll
just mention some results for fixed
groups at the end if you if we have
enough time so let me define our model
for growing groups first of all we
assume that although group members have
opinions which are real numbers between
0 and 1 this kind of modeling is pretty
standard in a political science folks
where their opinions model will one is
on the political spectrum between the
left and lights if we are considering an
academic domain then this numbers can be
how a theoretical go applied once which
is in my case we assume that our members
have these opinions which are between 0
& 1 and a lot of pictures that are
having this talk will be useful to put
each member on the location
corresponding his opinion and you will
see why so now this is going to are
going to analyze the process that works
in this kid time steps at every time
step we assume that two candidates will
arrive they want to join the group and
each one of them has an opinion door
from the uniform distribution and now
account members need to decide which
member to vote for and we'll still
reduce very simple volleyball so each
member is going to vote for the
candidate who is most similar to him who
is closer to him on the real line simply
because you want to make sure that the
group will be more similar to him he
will have a nice experience in this
group and let me take just very short
detour explaining a bit more about
rationale behind this voting go so one
of the well studied the phenomenon
forces in sociology is homophily this is
the tendency of people to prefer and
interact more with others were more
similar to them and this tendency can
manifest itself in those dimensions so
fix ones like age gender race you are
more behavioral ones like hobbies and
opinions just to give you a rough idea
on how it looks like so this network is
the friendship network in some high
school and different colors correspond
to different places and it's easy to see
that this network is pretty home office
with respect to the yellow and green
color so this is mostly and this is the
reason why we assume that our members
how voting for candidates that are
closer to them so they'll be having
weekly yes so they have you having way
up to clay and
what a nice to do it for the short term
making sure that no other man was little
closer to them will be admitted yes
um i guess it natural it is natural to
start from two candidates and already
the interesting things very interesting
same things happen for two candidates oh
oh you mean two candidate as opposed to
one candidate I mean one candidate you
can think of a variation of the model
but if you want the simplest model in
which there is actually a bit of
spiritual choice so choice between to
the two seems like the minimal number
and it's still good enough to get
interesting things going on I'll talk at
the end a bit about extensions but yes
definitely it's not like this to a more
candidate is interesting we have some
ideas on how to do that um okay so each
one of the members votes myopically for
the candidate closest to him and our
admission will basically takes all the
votes of the members and apply some
function to decide which candidate is
accepted to the group if any at all and
let's explore a couple of admission
rules that starts with a very simple one
so consensus this means that the
candidate will be accepted to the group
only if all the group members agree that
this candidate is better than the other
and initially one can suspect that some
strong requirement like this should make
the group be quite homogeneous this we
need the consent of everybody in order
to admit someone to the group but it's
actually not how to see that the exact
time the exact opposite thing is going
to happen so let's see why there's an
easy way of thinking about how the
members will vote so we can go this line
and this thread line is simply the
average between the opinions of the two
candidates now since every member is
voting for the candidate who is closer
to him this means that all the our
numbers on the right side will vote for
the right candidates all the members on
the left side will vote for the left
candidate now some require all
members to vote for the same candidate
that's require consensus this means that
will accept candidate only in the case
that this red line is to the left of the
green guy and since this red line is the
average between the opinions of the two
candidates this means that both of the
opinions are in this leftmost interval
or this red line is just to derive most
of the right candidate so in this case
the opinions are in this red interval so
in general only candidates in these two
and red intervals can join the group now
such there's always a positive for
ability of accepting a candidate here
and here as it's possible that both of
the candidates will be just right of the
rightmost candidate and left of the
leftmost candidate this means that as
time goes by these intervals are just
going to shrink and go further for 20
and 1 i'm sorry i don't see how you get
two candidates in your picture when you
grow up one line so the one line is just
the average between the opinions of the
two candidates um so I'll have a
slightly different picture in the next
slide and I think it will be clearer
then let's wait was this for like two
minutes okay and if it's still this is
the reasoning about is average and how
there are members vote is going to a bit
several times to talk and I think it
will be clear in the next slide so this
one okay oh yeah okay let's ask me again
exactly okay so articoli here is that
the concern submission walls which
initially seems like it's something that
you'd resort in homogeneous group
actually it's doing the exact same
opposite we get a completely polarized
group so let's consider now another
simple admission rule so so I understand
it yes if someone is to the left of
everyone and the other guys somewhere in
the middle yeah then then nobody wants
you know
it's actually and the other guys to the
and where's the other guy so both both
of them have to be either in this
interval or anything that's interval so
the average between them has to be
either here oh yes okay so yeah so at
some point here you'll just stop it yes
let's go it's more like a freeze its own
fun oh you like that you can also think
about it's it's polarizing yes and more
than that as time goes by it will take
you more and more and more time till you
admit another candidate so yes yes
you're right yes either thing about this
rule is violates and dependence of the
relevant intelligence which means that
the second candidate shows up we are not
choosing him but he will undermine my
meat on being chosen how is that in the
examples that you gave another I mean
make it happens in our faculty meeting
sometimes
don't you how often people haven't used
complete consensus also how often people
use this oh but you are right those
that's a good point I'm not sure exactly
how often
cool
um so talk about this yeah this is one
thing to learn to talk about next slide
any other questions yes you know i mean
the group always groves no one leaves
the group effort yes this was the
beginning i said it out to settings one
is setting up a growing group no one was
a fixed loop so this is the going go
stank okay let's move for the majority
admission cool so now we assume that the
canada that is voted by at least half of
the group is that mirrored and and for
the majority of machine roll it's
actually the case that every time step a
candidate will join the group and we can
write this some admission all and
slightly a different form to be easier
to work with so the candidate that is
closer to the middle of the group is
admitted so again we have all the
members of the group on this line okay
and now we have the two candidates Jason
to your questions and this line is the
average between the opinions so all the
people in this side are closer to the
right candidate more than to the left
candidate so they are going to vote for
the right candidate and all the people
on this side are closer to the left
candidate so they were to vote for the
left candidate now since we are require
the candidate that joins the group to
have at least a majority then this means
that the candidate that would join the
group is the one that the median is on
his side on the side of the virtual to
him so basically the candidate closet
dominion is the one that is admitted to
the coop um so that's the nice
description of tall to work with and
what we show is that basically
regardless of the initial conditions the
group is going to become a central group
who is a triangle shaped distribution
and its median is going to approach half
so just to give you a sense on how this
looks like these are pictures from a
simulation with them so we started this
group with anything two members one
located at point two they are one is
locally at the point eight
and this picture here every point is the
member it was accepted around the height
is his opinion you can see lot from this
picture but you can see that the middle
area here is much denser than there is
on the side and to give you a better
idea of how it looks like this is the
histogram of the opinions of all the
members when group reached the size of
20 thousands so it looks kind of like
it's triangle and I want to give you
some intuition on how we prove this
theorem and the main part of upon the
serum is showing that the median
converges to half so I will do it in the
next slide and I just want to give you
to explain why once we have that the
median converges to half the
distribution will converge to this
triangle distribution or more
specifically it will converge to this
distribution so let's assume for a
second that the median is located that
exactly half so this means that if a
candidate is located at X X is less than
half then he has a probability of
exactly 2 X to be admitted since this is
the probability that the candidate is
more far from him will are we appear and
since we have two candidates to a
computer density function we should
multiply this by two now once we have
that the median is not exactly at half
but close to half this becomes a bit
more noisy but it's still the case that
distribution will approach is triangle
distribution sort of they give you some
intuition on why the median converge to
half and we'll need a bit of notation so
first of all we did not a group of size
K by SK and its median by ms k and
formally we show that for any group of
size sk 0 and any epsilon greater than 0
with high probability will exist k
epsilon such that for every K prime
Gator than K epsilon the distance
between the median of the group and half
is less than epsilon yes once the media
convergence that have followed by
symmetry right so it's really the fact
that it converges to anything that
that's the phone
I think you're right we the poo actually
put both together don't think that's a
silly convergys toast yes confer just to
a constant yes they depend on this story
inside independent of the initial
configuration yeah the half is
independent of each other so what is the
poor idea so we're going to consider a
group of size K and we assume here that
case large enough and furthermore we
assume it initially we started the group
forum size one and the group go using
our majority admission roll dated
preacher size of K and at this point the
median is located at half minus epsilon
epsilon here is greater than zero so
this is a group somehow here and this at
the media and our first show that when
we double the group size the median
moves slides by about 2 epsilon square K
members so this is the this is all
minion it's the new minion and about 12
external squared K points between them
now it's possible that is two optional
squad points are really concentrated in
a very small interval of negligible
length so in the second step we show
that every 2 epsilon squared K
consecutive members actually lined an
interval of lengths at least epsilon
square over 2 and these two steps
together while speaking imply that after
about 1 over epsilon square double
length then a median gets to a distance
of epsilon over to from half so it's
actually getting closer to have in the
next two slides will give you some in
some more intuition how we prove these
steps and then I tell you why this idea
is not very accurate yes
um so we only studied a uniform
distribution that's also interesting
extensions ah we don't we don't you i'm
not sure what i would happen for other
distributions yeah and I these tips are
true with highfather probably or
something like that 40 I mean it's
everything with high probability but
that's not the problem no okay yeah
everything is roughly speaking high
probability yes that's just an intuition
it's not a complete formal poof um okay
because this is real if distance so
cannot translate this to contacts
because quantized equal contents that
they got any color you clear distance
what are you fellas have to do this
sorry it what happens in this hundred
million people's preferences as right or
a different distribution I'm saying
firstly the idea of resetting to ponder
is not going to work and it's also the
Train transformational distance
okay um so when doubling the group size
want to show that the median moves side
by about 2 epsilon square K members so
let's say that the confidence here at
half minus epsilon and our first observe
that by symmetry the probability of
accepting candidate here is the same as
the probability of accepting a candidate
here and these two end of us have the
same length both of them have candidates
on the same distance from half minus
epsilon so we can assume that they are
speaking in the K steps that we in case
the group of size K 20 K then of a
candidate that will admit it here and
here is the same now in this in grey
interval the probability of accepting a
candidate is for epsilon squared since
this is an interval of length 2 epsilon
and the only way of accepting a
candidate in this interval is if both
candidates lined this interval this
happens with probability of 4 epsilon
squared so again with high probability
roughly speaking about 4 epsilon squared
K candidates will join this interval so
this means that the number of candidates
that joined to the right of this medium
is graded by 4 epsilon squared K then
the number of members the joint to the
left of this median so the median has to
move left so I has been white by 2
epsilon square K points now want to show
that these two epsilon square points
line interval of size which is at least
epsilon square over 2 so we call it we
started a group from size 1 so we have
we had a 2k rounds in which we admitted
a candidate yes oh we have to we had to
carry arms in which we are admitted
candidates so overall we observed for K
candidates since all candidates are
drawn from the uniform distribution at
every interval of size Delta we've seen
about for Delta K candidates this is an
upper bound on the number of members we
accepted to this interval so overall our
two epsilon square K points have to lie
in interval of length at least
epsilon squared over to and from these
two steps together who get it after
about one of epsilon square double links
the median gets to distance of epsilon
over to from Earth now what's wrong with
the proof is this intuition the problem
is that we assume here that the median
Emma Skye staged at the same place all
the time for all the K lands in between
case the group and it's not really
correct because the median keeps moving
each time that we admit more members the
median moves like he moves and this also
affects the probability of accepting
candidates which left into its right so
this is something that we need to really
take into account or what much harder in
order to earn in order to take care of
um so we've been talking about the the
the consensus admission role we've seen
it converge to some kind of polarized
the committee and also about them
agility which Tennyson converges to a
triangular distribution and I will talk
a bit about what happens in the middle
between the two and we'll do it in a
slightly different model so this is a
model where the group has a founder the
founder is located 21 and he's the one
setting the atmosphere for the group so
we give him a very special special veto
power only the candidate that this
founder prefers might be admitted to the
group and and since this founder is
located at one this implies that only
the right candidate can be admitted to
the group and now this right candidate
will be admitted only fair are greater
than zero faction of the members in the
group actually prefer the right member
over the last number so if for example r
is greater than point fall then no one
will be admitted but in this example if
all is less than point six then there's
enough concern to admit this right guy
to the hoop and four is the veto
admission walls the oh sorry and again
similar to what we did before we can
have
alternative description of the soul so
now the right candidate is accepted only
a fraction of at least all of the group
likes here or in other words the Y minus
a quarter of the group is here it's
about them the average of the two
candidates since this means that the
faction of Y minus all of the group is
to its left and a faction of out of the
group it to his right slice here um so
for this video's does something quite
interesting happening we have a phase
transition when our equals half so if I
is getting in half then this process is
going to behave quite similar to
consensus so as time goes by we are only
going to accept members closer and
closer to zero but when r is less than
half this is going to behave pretty
similar to the majority admission go to
zero it's exactly the opposite so the
founder is at one and what happens is
even if this father has this power of
only accepting the gate can the right
candidates still what's going to happen
is that with time only candidates cause
and closer to zero will will join the
group so in some sense it's much
stronger result so when I is less than
half then is going to converge to a
continuous distribution at untainted
tile distribution this is quite similar
to a majority um so I was planning on
give you some intuition on how we prove
this theorem what I'm going to skip that
I just want to show this is the picture
of how the tank pancetta the triangle
the distribution look like so basically
this is the function of al p heel equals
y minus l and as I'll gets closer to
zero this gets closer to being a
straight line and we always about a half
then this will be a triangle similar to
the majority
so that's me I guess get somebody okay
so um we talked about the model in which
members of the group select new members
based on the similarity based on who
mostly in a model different admission
rules have vertical applications on the
range of opinions in the group for if we
recall consensus then the group is going
to become polarized majority the group
will have this kind of tangled shape
distribution and in the middle we have
an interesting phase transition so for
the special videos we have that it's
either would behave similar to consensus
or behave more similar to majority now
since we used homophily as the driving
force behind the members vote mr. work
is related to walks on opinion formation
and cultural dynamics that very roughly
speaking also consider questions such as
how who mostly affects the opinion mix
in network and many natural extensions
as people have already suggested so
considering k candidates at the rabbit
and allowed over candidates that are
drawn from distribution other than the
uniform also our admission rules so for
example just the p majority so point 75
prefer one candidate over the other
without the restriction to lv rules but
going to stop here so thanks yeah ravine
my office so it's an excellent question
a little to my right that will mean our
party will slide to the right but there
isn't far left that we can slide so I'm
pretty safe taking someone much for it
yeah that's an excellent question we
don't know like an interesting question
was that like you have disaster the last
word on your cycle on the last EP
majority oh we don't have results on
this model we have some simulations that
suggests that there's also going to be a
similar fashion Elysium only now if you
require more majority of greater than
three quarters it will be have similar
to consensus you'll get something
polarized and if you require majority
between half and three quarters it will
be something similar to a triangle
distribution a bit under a continuous
distribution looks kind of the same but
analyzing these kind of force is much
more difficult because you basically
need to track two points so in the model
we studied you only need to take just
one point so just the peak want a
quarter of some fraction and 4p majority
you'll need to click both the peak want
other than one minus P cuanto which
makes it much more difficult to analyze
just not you it was clear but that's
kind of the reason why this is much more
difficult but also it's very interesting
yeah any more questions could you think
about design if you had some kind of
objective for the group it would be the
best
seems like yeah I guess it's a question
of virtual girl basically concerns is
probably not a good idea that's I guess
the main conclusion but not sure what
else they couldn't get I can say